[Music]
what do you consider yourself I'm more
of a hostess I guess you can pay me for
my company or you don't have to pay me
at all you're a model God man I'm an
actress I'm an enigma you're an enigma
I'm saying I probably told you about I'm
scared I'm not doing this in the right
way you go you know that game I don't
know what you're talking about
you think we should see each other
[Music]
I know this is crazy I'm a good person
and I brought you here to be with me
because I just want you to get to know
what do you want you want to date me hey
there in the basement I know what you
call it but just why we just want a
chance to get me something do you think
that's going to die I do
isn't that we can hang out you know
that's nice enjoy is that you let me in
your house before are you taking a huge
step :
yep in a zone of us begin back quick I
can't stop thinking about you
my brain tells me to run my heart tells
me to stay I have to tell you something
hey we can fix this it'll be like it
never happened
you